>> Sean: JOINING US NOW THE
HOST OF CRTV'S LEVIN TV AND
HOST OF LIFE, LIBERTY LEVIN
NUMBER ONE SHOW HERE SUNDAY
NIGHT 10:00 P.M.
I CALL HIM THE GREAT ONE.
WELL, GREAT ONE, I LOOK AT
THIS, THE PART OF ME, AND I
KNOW HOW MUCH YOU LOVE THE
CONSTITUTION.
YOU HAVE DEDICATED YOUR
ENTIRE LIFE TO STUDYING OUR
CONSTITUTION.
WRITING ABOUT OUR
CONSTITUTION, TALKING ABOUT
IT.
AND I READ THIS, AND I SEE
AN AMERICA THAT DOESN'T
REMIND ME OF THE ONE OUR
FOUNDERS PUT TOGETHER BUT A
TWO TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND I -- IT BREAKS MY HEART
AND HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
IF WE ARE GOING TO FIX THIS.
>> I WILL TELL YOU WHAT I
SEES A I WENT THROUGH THIS
MAINLY REPORT HERE, I SEE
SEVERAL THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, OUT OF ALL THE
TEXTS.
ALL THE DOCUMENTS, ALL THE
EMAILS THAT HAVE BEEN
REVIEWED.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING, SEAN?
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE
PRO-TRUMP TEXT.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
ANTI-HILLARY TEXT.
PRO-TRUMP SENIOR FBI
OFFICIAL.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
ANTI-HILLARY FBI OFFICIAL.
THIS WAS A CAN A
THIS WAS A CAB A
THIS WAS A CABAL.
THESE PEOPLE HAD AS THEIR
PURPOSE TO INTERFERE WITH A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THEY INTERFEARED WITH THIS
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION WORSE
THAN THE RUSSIAN COULD SAY
HAVE EVER DREAMED OF.
AND I'M NOT FAN OF VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND THE RUSSIANS.
LET ME TELL YOU THAT JAMES
COMEY'S FBI, THERE WAS
COLLUSION.
THE MEDIA IN THIS REPORT
APPAL AND GIVING GIFTS AND
TICKETS TO SPORTING EVENTS
AND GOLF OUTINGS AND
EXCHANGE, APPARENTLY FOR
LEAKS.
YOU HAVE A CULL PURR OF
LEAKS AT THE FBI.
THE BUCK STOPS WITH COMEY.
THIS IS COMEY.
COMEY DISGRACED.
MCCABE, CRIMINAL REFERRALS.
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF AN
FBI LIKE THIS.
YOU HAVE OBSTRUCTION JIM
COMEY SPENT MONTHS TRY
POSITION MAKE SURE SHAH
HILLARY CLINTON WAS
PROTECTED.
DO YOU KNOW WHY IN IF WE HAD
IMPANGED THE FEDERAL GRAND
JURY AND PLAYED BY THE BOOK
SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN
INDICTED.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WOULD
HAVE HAD TO HAVE ANOTHER
CONVENTION AND FIND ANOTHER
CANDIDATE.
THEY COULDN'T ALLOW THAT
THEY HAD TO DEFEAT TRUMP.
COMEY INSUBORDINATE.
USURPING THE POWER LINES OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE ASSOCIATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
INSUBORDINATE.
HAVE YOU COLLUSION.
OBSTRUCTION,
INSUBORDINATION.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNBELIEVABLE.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO THE
MEDIA.
THE MEDIA, WHICH SINGS LIKE
A BUNCH OF BLACK BIRDS ON A
TELEPHONE POLE.
THEY MOVE IN ONE DIRECTION
THEY ALL MOVE IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION.
WE KNOW WHY.
THE MEDIA WAS WORKING, MUCH
OF THE MEDIA WITH THE FBI.
WHAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
DOESN'T TELL US FOR SOME
REASON WHICH MEDIA.
WHICH REPORTERS WHICH FBI
AGENTS.
WE WANT TO KNOW.
AND THEY DON'T TELL US.
NOW, THERE IS SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THEY
HAVE IN THIS REPORT.
IT WAS HILARIOUS.
CHUCK SCHUMER RUNS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR TO IMMEDIATELY
DEFEND COMEY EXCEPT AS IT
COMES TO HILLARY CLINTON AND
SAYS AND STARTS TALKING
ABOUT THE REPORT.
CHUCK SCHUMER HADN'T TIME TO
READ THIS REPORT NEITHER DID
ANY OF THE OTHER DEMOCRATS
RUNNING TO THE MEDIA.
AND THEY ALL SOUND THE SAME
BECAUSE THEY ALL HAVE THE
SAME TALKING POINTS.
HERE'S HIS RECOMMENDATIONS,
THE IG.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI
CONSIDERING DEVELOPING
GUIDANCES THAT IDENTIFIES
THE RISKS ASSOCIATE YOU HAVE
HAD WITH AND ALTERNATIVES
FOR PERMITTING A WITNESS TO
ATTEND THE VOLUNTARY
INTERVIEW OF ANOTHER
WITNESS.
THAT'S ALREADY DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE POLICY THAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT COMEY ALLOWED
THE CLINTON WITNESSES TO
COLLUDE WE RECOMMEND THE
DEPARTMENT CONSIDER MAKING
EXPLICIT, THAT EXCEPT IN
SITUATIONS FOR THE LAW
REQUIRES TORE PERMITS
DISCLOSURE AN INVESTIGATING
AGENCY CANNOT PUBLICLY
ANNOUNCE ITS RECOMMENDING
CHARGING DECISION PRIOR TO
GENERAL THAT'S ALREADY
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
POLICY.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI
CONSIDER ADOPTING A POLICY
ADDRESSING THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES
DISCUSSING THE CONDUCT OF
UNCHARGED INDIVIDUALS IN
PUBLIC STATEMENTS.
THAT'S ALREADY DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE POLICY.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CONSIDER
PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO AGENTS
AND PROSECUTORS CONCERNING
THE TAKING OF OVERT TREAIVE
STEPS, INDICTMENTS, PLUCK
ANNOUNCEMENTS OR OTHER THAT
COULD IMPACT ELECTION.
THAT'S ALREADY DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE POLICY.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT, I
WATCHED THIS FBI DIRECTOR
WRAY HAVE HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE AND LEARNED
EXACTLY NOTHING AND ONE OF
THE THINGS HE DID THAT I
FOUND VERY TROUBLE LING TO
ME SAID LOOK, ONE OF THE
THINGS WE ARE GOING TO DO TO
FIX THIS AND WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE VERY SIGNIFICANT
TRAINING OF ALL OF OUR
AGENTS, NEW AGENTS, SENIOR
AGENTS, ALL THOUSANDS OF
AGENTS THAT THEY NEED TO BE
UNBIASED IN THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
AND I THOUGHT TO MYSELF THEY
ARE UNBIASED IN THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE FBI
SUN BIASED IN
INVESTIGATIONS.
WHY ARE YOU TRASHING YOUR
OWN AGENCY?
THE PROBLEM ISN'T JOE FBI
AGENT OR SALLY FBI AGENT.
THE PROBLEM IS JIM COMEY.
THE PROBLEM IS STRZOK.
THE PROBLEM IS PAGE.
THE PROBLEM IS THEIR OWN
CROWD.
I FOUND IT INCREDIT DIB
BAILIFF OUTRAGEOUS OF THE
FBI DIRECTOR.
I HAPPEN TO KNOW IT IS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, EVERYBODY
NEEDS TO BE TRAINED NOT TO
BE BIASED?
THIS REPORT, EVEN THOUGH THE
IG SAYS HE DIDN'T FIND
POLITICAL BIAS, I HAVE TO
SAY THERE IS BIAS THROUGHOUT
AND HE USES THE WORD
THROUGHOUT BUT I WOULD ASK
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WHAT
KIND OF BIAS ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT SEXUAL BIAS; RELIGIOUS
BIAS?
OF COURSE IT WAS POLITICAL
BIAS.
AS STARTED OUT BY SAYING
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE
PRO-TRUMP TEXT FROM ANY OF
THESE FBI AGENTS.
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE
PRO-TRUMP FBI AGENT.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
OBJECTIVE.
THEY HAVE POLITICIZED IT TO
SUCH AN EXTENT AND THE
REASON, THE REASON IS AS I
SAID THEY HAD TO PROTECT
HILLARY CLINTON BECAUSE SHE
WOULD HAVE AND SHOULD HAVE
BEEN INDICTED.
SO, HILLARY, I SAW YOUR
LITTLE TWEET TODAY, KIND OF
THINKING WELL, SIGH, EVEN
COMEY USED HIS PERSONAL
EMAIL FOR GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS BUT HILLARY YOU
VIOLATED THE ESPIONAGE ACT
AND JIM COMEY PROTECTED YOU,
YOU COULD VERY WELL BE IN AN
ORANGE JUMPSUIT TODAY AND
I'M QUITE, QUITE SERIOUS
THAT YOU AREN'T AND YOU
SHOULD THANK GOD FOR THAT.
>> Sean: GREAT ONE, MARK
LEVIN.
BY THE WAY I HAVE A MUTUAL
FROM A KNEW ACTUAL FRIEND
BILLY SAYS WOW TELL MARK
GREAT RANT.